[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
Financial Inclusion we have Andres and
most of you joining us on the show hey
everyone I'm glad to be here
that's super excited to have you brother
very excited that John UK join
introduced us which is very kind of him
and now we're gonna be talking about
Financial Inclusion blockchain
cryptocurrency very excited for this
Andre is the founder and CEO of Amba
safe which makes financial markets
universally accessible by tokenizing
equity of pre-ipo companies as well as
helping early-stage companies launch
their token offerings Andre launched the
first merchant service for Bitcoin in
2013 called bitmerge and the first multi
currency wallet called holy transaction
in 2014 he also holds the first
university degree in cryptocurrency
and you can find the links below to
order book IO and be safe calm holy
transaction calm and the SpaceX offering
for their pre IPO is coming up on June
10th there's a minimum $100 investment
for that and also the Twitter for Aundre
will be unpacking all of that more as we
go let's jump into things with one of
our favorite questions what are your
thoughts on the direction of our world
sure I think the world is going into the
direction of accelerating I think the
world is an educational simulator so I'm
I'm a believer in simulation theory so I
think it's an educational game and we
are here to learn something although we
forgot what and what I see is happening
is that the game speed is accelerating
things are happening faster and faster
and all technology all like economy
trends they they all just accelerate
which accelerates the process of
learning on the personal scale and on a
community and global scale well that's
good stuff okay so we're here to learn
but we forgot what exact
exactly it's a learning simulator right
okay and then this pace of economic
growth and change that's happening is
making learning faster right okay and
then one of the things is to be able to
help people learn faster which is kind
of part of this Financial Inclusion
yeah general trend of movement of the
economy into the digital form and
digitization of everything is is
accelerating it whatever you you make
digital it becomes faster
so once economy is moved when economy is
moving to the digital form things start
to go faster like it used to take for a
company for a company between five and
ten years to go from nowhere to an IPO
phase and with the ICO it became
possible in the year or less to go from
nowhere to a public offering stage so
both companies and investors who
participated in that learned their
lessons faster if the company was
supposed to fail it has failed faster if
it was supposed to succeed it succeeded
faster like etherium have succeeded to
some extent a lot of agios have failed
and currently they're worth nothing so
it's been taken ten years before it
became digital oh yeah
okay so the permutations that we run of
different startups and ideas can now
with icos you can know about their
success or failure potentially faster in
a year or two or five or ten yeah well
whenever the process has happening in
digital form instead of paper or
physical yeah yeah so it's not exactly
the ico what makes it faster its
movement of of the business model into
the digital form so it's the fact that I
can now with my own voting power I can
say I like your idea digitally here's my
digital lighting of your idea versus
having to handle it in the physical
world right okay
I like that this view is very good okay
well we'll end up coming back to this at
the very end again and I'm looking
forward to it
the bolt out of the consensus technology
decentralized consensus technology but
also just simulation theory in general
this would be very good okay now let's
jump into your journey so you're born in
Ukraine and you started programming when
you're nine years old that's right what
hooked you into a program yes so parents
were bringing me into their offices and
they were letting me play some computer
games and I I started asking more and
more complicated questions like how to
put this game on how to switch to the
next level in this game and then what
happens if I edit this character in the
source code of the game so eventually
they were not they were not able to
answer the questions so instead they
they bought me some book about low level
programming in assembler language when I
was seven or eight I read that I'm
actually understood some of it and I
started writing programs on paper based
on that book for university students
when I was eight so yeah this is how I
gotten into programming this is a
reoccurring theme is that sometimes the
ones that are you get hooked into
programming when they're young they want
to make changes in the video games that
they're playing yeah I was just trying
to hack video games and ended up writing
a lot of software and then what were you
doing in your teenage years with
programming lots of things I've started
lunch in websites when I was 12
so initially I started with writing
viruses for my classmates with games
just to practice my virus right writing
skills it was fun and then once I got
connected to the internet I immediately
got engaged into IRC worse there were
wars between IRC channels happened where
people were trying to take over the
channels using some automated warbots
so I was writing IRC
but that that were aimed so I take over
in certain IRC channels so I was already
meaning Internet Relay Chat relation
this is where people use the hangout and
the internet before online chat rooms
and social networks came into existence
yes I met a lot of real hackers there
learned some hacking skills learnt a lot
of so it's basically a dark map all the
darknet communication is happening in
the IRC so I got into that first and
only then I got into normal web yeah
then I started launching websites with
collections of these scripts for IRC
then I got into more conventional gaming
like Starcraft so I've launched I wrote
a tournament system for Ukrainian
Starcraft community just because I
thought it would be nice to have and
when I was 14 and then the owner of the
of that community website offered me a
job he didn't know the time for team
might I don't remember
so I started lunching more and more
websites every least my once the number
of websites have lunched exceeded them I
realized that I need a content
management system so I've developed a
website content management system like
like a wordpress but another one and
started launching websites based on that
it became an open source project some
people started contributing so I've
launched an open source project when I
was 14 I didn't know that it's called
back then and
yeah then I started doing some stuff for
money oh and a lot of it is under NDA so
you can switch to the next question
[Laughter]
interesting here you talk about the
scripts in the Internet Relay Chat and
then to try and take them over things
like that also the the latter work with
website development and then building
you open it up actually open sourcing
the the content management for the
websites which is actually very cool to
build something in an open source about
14 yeah yeah that's good stuff
okay then the interest in blockchain
technology came up yeah
so it's a long story but we have time I
started watching conspiracy movies when
I was 16 I think a lot of them were
talking about some shadow government
behind the federal reserve some behind
the scenes government how world is ruled
by bankers this is all wrong and should
be changed but none of those movies were
offering a solution to the problem and
so I went to a couple of local meetups
of anarchists in Ukraine to see what
what other people with the same
interests are doing and they weren't
really doing anything cool they were
discussing moving to Iike villages as a
solution basically to disconnect him
from the capitalist system by going
offline like hiding in the woods it
didn't seem like a solution on a large
scale to me so I had this idea that I
came up to this idea that if I if I can
raise money from lots of these people
who want to change the world but doesn't
but don't know how and hire a couple of
students and let them and let them play
with em ideas of alternative economies
eventually they will come up maybe to
some working solution that that can
scale so if published everything and
published this proposal in 2008 about
luncheon and
Unser's experimental project of
alternative financial system and they've
published it at one of the russian
anarchist forums it was called zeitgeist
movement it was due to the name of one
of the movies and I was in Ukraine
I was located in Ukraine but I've
published it at Russian forum in the
project proposal section full of other
energies proposals and four hours later
the post got removed for no obvious
reason to me and I wrote two moderators
like what the [ __ ] what was wrong with
the post it was a legit proposal nobody
responded to me and the next day I got a
phone call from somebody with an
identified number and they were like hey
mr somavia I have a serious letter to
you listen carefully if you don't stop
all work with computer your family will
get health issues you will be taken care
of by special forces of Russian
Federation goodbye
this is how I got in the drawing so this
is where I realized that I found
something something some really valuable
idea because I got a call from Russian
intelligence agency asking me to not
work on this idea
and yeah for the next two weeks I was
like I was really afraid I thought the
time under continuous surveillance by
Russian intelligence while in Ukraine
and I was afraid to touch my phone to
touch my computer because I stopped and
their surveillance and they asked me to
not and I quit my job because they told
me to not touch computer anymore so I
just calls to my employer and said that
I can't work with computer anymore with
no explanation and I just sat at home
and was thinking about some alternative
of wine business ideas like opening a
coffee shop or something like that but
they all seemed pretty boring so I've
found a compromise with myself I
I've decided to take a job of like
project manager so I don't write code by
myself so in case I will be tortured in
the basements of KGB I will have an
excuse that I didn't write code myself
and yes for the next year I worked at
marketing agency as a manager without
doing anything really interesting and
year later I thought like [ __ ] no I
really want to work on this idea and we
we have a question from the viewers the
the pentagram is a part of the first
language that's stuck with AI D mind
programming or at least a star with the
circle why are few code or spiritual
when so much leads to the existential
yeah I know it's hard it's a hard
question I yeah I think we'll we might
we might have to to to ask for a little
bit more clarification yeah will will
scrap it well yeah we might have to ask
for a little more clarification maybe
that had something to do with coding and
spirituality yeah we can't get into
simulation theory questions at the end
yeah to not interrupt the story yes yes
sure sorry
sure you're good no worries yes
so yeah later I've decided to resume the
project I decided to do it by myself
right at anonymously unpublished
anonymously and see if it takes off and
I googled just in case somebody has done
something similar Julian this year and
discovered that some Japanese guy called
Satoshi Nakamoto has released a very
similar project and it's called Bitcoin
and even had a forum with hundred users
so I decided to research it deep deeper
and I went to that forum and
investigated source code of Bitcoin and
this is the right time to pull up the
screenshot okay awesome let's get that
up so then okay so then this was you in
that for yeah so this is me in 2010
after I just discovered bit
asking how it works and I didn't like
the idea that nodes were connecting via
IRC Network because I've participated in
that IRC channel worse I knew how easy
it is to shut down a channel or I
receive Network and if I'm not wrong up
until 2012 Bitcoin decentralization was
relying on existence of a centralized
IRC Network it was really easy to shut
down the entire Bitcoin network by
shutting down a couple of IRC servers
which I didn't like
also I didn't like the idea of mining so
I asked questions authors of Bitcoin so
to clarify is it do I get it right and
after Satoshi responded that yes you got
it right why is the transaction fee
needed decentralized node list protected
from potential situations when a node is
hacked so you're asking questions yet as
of the day today they look like a very
basic questions but it was 2010 this is
nine years ago
yeah only like one or two persons in the
world which were Satoshi I'm Gavin
Anderson and understood how Bitcoin
works like that yeah yeah yeah okay and
then you ended up getting an answer here
and you're and yeah this was interesting
yeah so this is actually yeah Satoshi
and the answer was four days later yes
after figuring out that bitcoin is still
rely on the Bitcoin is relying on the
IRC Network and that mining if there is
there I didn't really like the idea of
mining and I think it can be argued that
it doesn't scale well if you analyze the
structure of mining pools today it's
really centralized
I decided to continue working on my own
cryptocurrency and for the next two
years I've been doing it as a side
project four hours per week while
traveling to different festivals I
didn't really take it too seriously it
was just a fun idea to work on up until
2012 I think
no Bitcoin exchanges existed I don't
remember precisely date when mount GOx
went live but Bitcoin costed less than a
penny and up until 2013 it wasn't clear
at all how much it will cost it costed
like less than penny per Bitcoin so I
didn't buy much and I kept working on my
own cryptocurrencies believing that the
Bitcoin will fail because of the
centralization issues and mining and
some others okay so there's a couple
things here first is you in 2008 had
already published your own idea of how
to decentralize 2009 2009 your own idea
of how to decentralize the global
banking infrastructure and then you had
that crazy call from the Intelligence
Agency that's nuts that's crazy
and then you ended up kind of you know
having a particular hands off for a
little bit but then you found again into
US and ten this happening and you when
you when you saw this happening you saw
an aspect of centralization with mining
so with the way that the next blocks are
created you wanted a way that
potentially wasn't a centralized amount
of compute power that could maybe be the
most optimal there'd be the highest
efficiency at making that next I just
saw that people who got into mining
really early according to how it is
designed they get like in proportion in
proportionally higher returns and in
power in the system compared to the ones
who got ladies ladies you can it's a
it's a power loss so like with anything
the earliest ones that get the most
amount of traction early yeah I usually
stay at the top yeah and to me it looked
like wait so in proportion I'd like I
wanted to be much more even distribution
of initial yeah currency in the system
and this is the questions that you were
asking the things you were thinking
about it the early days yeah okay and
then okay then in 2012 you had your own
current cryptocurrency that you were
also working on yes I kept working on my
own kata currency for the next two years
while Bitcoin was like in like the below
the 1 cent in price and when my currency
was finished by like it was like 70
percent finished maybe 50 Bitcoin
started to take off and because I needed
cryptocurrency so to be able to to
launch my other businesses in first
place so if the currency wasn't the goal
itself I actually decided to work on the
invent financial system to be able to
operate businesses in the internet
without dependency on the local
government approvals or a local
financial system it's close to
impossible to to operate a business in
Ukraine especially small business where
I was based and I've discovered that I'm
unable to accept credit cards from like
more than five countries I have to pay
taxes that didn't make sense I mean it's
easier to not launch a business with the
taxes that they impose on you in Ukraine
Wow
yes so I've decided to try to invent an
alternative financial system that would
let me operate a business with freedom
no it's it's more freedom for globally
regardless of where I am and it was the
main motivation and because Bitcoin
solved that issue because Bitcoin
started to take off and we finally got a
currency that works globally no matter
where you are with any
internet-connected device I've decided
to start testing my business idea on
Bitcoin instead of completing my own
currency so I've put it on hold for a
little bit I ended up passing it as a
thesis project in university instead of
one channel just to have it saved
somewhere and I don't think Ukrainian
University where I
like presented it understood what I was
talking about I think they still don't
know
but in their archives they have like one
of the first cryptocurrencies that were
developed and I got the diploma with
cryptocurrency as a thesis project and
then I've started lunch in businesses
for for Bitcoin and I blanched the first
merchant service so my English let's
talk right before that very cool how the
first university degree in
cryptocurrency that's so interesting and
hopefully many more inbox encrypted
currency testing thesis projects very
cool stuff then you left Ukraine for San
Francisco prior to making the big merch
and holy transaction so teachers about
what in 2013 got you wanting to come out
to San Francisco yeah so initially I was
invited here for a short business trip
but I took a walk around the mission and
discovered that I didn't like this place
there are a lot of hippies electronic
music psychedelic culture and all these
tech companies and they are all yes I
just sat on the grass and the Dolores
Park and in less than a minute some guy
offered me to buy mushrooms and acid
without like even even having to look
for it seemed like a really nice
customer service so I really loved this
place yeah I didn't think too much more
before moving here more business
opportunities more open mind writers
okay okay
and yeah Ron how was the acid yeah cuz
Ron's looking for some connection
[Laughter]
okay so then that ended up getting you
into this first merchant service for
Bitcoin in 2013 called bitmerge yeah
okay so teach us about that so my goal
is to make sure that blockchain
technology gets adopted worldwide and I
had a lot of hypotheses about what's
what's missing for that adoption yeah my
first hypothesis was that an ability to
easily accept Bitcoin for websites was
missing so I've developed
a paypal like service that allowed any
website by inviting a piece of HTML code
to start accepting Bitcoin in less than
10 minutes and it's got some some demand
but it wasn't significant enough as soon
I quickly discovered that the bigger
problem is lack of keep the currency in
the wallets and it may sound funny and
obvious today but again back in 2013 it
wasn't obvious at all what's what's
missing so the next thing that I've
built is an integrated exchange that
allowed people to buy bitcoins first
using their credit card and then pay to
those websites who invited the accept
Bitcoin button so it was kind of
reviewers of what a lot of merchant
services are doing today for Bitcoin and
then I discovered that wallets and
missing and yeah so I moved to San
Francisco in 2013 got accepted to a
startup accelerator here and we've
graduated with a multi currency wallet
that had integrated exchange to switch
easily between doors Cohen and litecoin
and Bitcoin and some integrated API is
for merchants and and so on but it
wasn't enough again in 2014 all
cryptocurrencies startups saw the same
picture the growth of the users has been
exponential until then and then it kind
of got more flat and linear and I think
what has happened there is Bitcoin has
reached the market the size of the
market of people who can understand it
without additional education to fool the
problem of centralized currencies like
Federal Reserve's corrupt bankers and so
on it seemed like a big problem people
who cared about it by 2014 most of them
have found Bitcoin the rest of the
people they didn't see any value they
acquired education
they wanted to see like what where
transaction fees or 20% discounts on
goods they they didn't see the reason to
like learning how Bitcoin works to deal
with all this software completely easy
onboarding yes so it became really clear
to me in 2014 that the main problem with
before 2013 my assumption was that if we
give people tools they will unleash
themselves they will quickly pick up
this instrument and the world will
transform and after that I realized that
it's not the lack of tools what is the
main problem it's education most of the
people don't even know that that the
problem exists that bankers are corrupt
and so on they don't understand so they
are not looking for tools and this is
why Bitcoin started to grow much slower
after 2014 once that early adopter
population was on board and yeah that's
a great way of explaining it that
there's always a time period where the
market becomes saturated with the people
that are wanting to solve the problem
and understand it and then there's a
certain amount of education that's
required for those that are late later
on the adapt adaption curve and so
that's a that's a that's a great point
because then how do you get them engaged
and involved if there's already uh
there's some friction with needing
education about what the technology is
there's a lack of user experience that's
really easy to get engaged with it so
it's good that you know catching on to
that so then that was both bitmerge and
holy transaction yeah yes ok so then
then you know for the last four and a
half years now it's been founder and CEO
of Amma safe and you were teaching me
about how this is really about the the
Financial Inclusion the financial
markets become making them become
universally accessible so it's
everything from the early stage
companies with launching their token
offerings all the way to the pre IPO
company yes I've experienced the problem
of Financial Inclusion personally
several times first time when I was
launched in websites or trying to lunch
business out of Ukraine
based on credit cards infrastructure
that didn't really work if you are
biased anywhere outside of the developed
countries and the second time when I
tried to raise money for my
cryptocurrencies project from Ukrainian
investors in 2011 I got I got like
second place in the software architects
competition but I got 10th out of them
places in the project ideas competition
for from my cryptocurrency project there
wasn't a single investor I talked to who
didn't say that it's crazy and it's not
going to work like there were not there
were no investors in Ukraine who could
understand what I was talking about in
2011 but there were in San Francisco
maybe just a few so a company with a
very similar business model that I was
proposing called ripple have been trying
to raise money at the same at the same
time but they were based in San
Francisco not in Ukraine so they've
raised 500k for their little
cryptocurrency project and now they're
one of the biggest and most successful
keep the currency companies so that if
the difference is location so they were
located in one of the economic centers
of the world
I was located in like the middle of
nowhere and yes so fast forward I've
started ten be safe after I seen that
Bitcoin is not going too far because of
the lack of education but a lot of
entrepreneurs have tried to have been
trying to launch all sorts of
experimental coins and tokens some of
them were backed by gold some of them
were backed by some other experimental
economic models so it was pretty obvious
that there will be a lot of
cryptocurrencies and some of them will
eventually succeed but I didn't know
which one so I didn't want to commit to
any of cryptocurrencies specifically and
because of the wallet company data that
I've launched before we were getting a
lot of requests the white label our
wallet software so I've started at NBC
with the idea that most of the companies
who would benefit from blockchain
technology actually not blockchain
companies they don't have to understand
how the technology works so I've started
the company that allowed companies to
launch their tokens easily to experiment
with their business ideas and we were
launching some experimental stuff for
the first two years 2015-2016 one of the
of those experimental projects survived
and succeeded it's desert the white
sands towel wallet software to tether
and then at the end of 2016 the wave of
I SEOs kicked in it was the next killer
up after the currency and we happens to
be the only company on the market that
had the solution the solution that
everyone was looking for the software to
launch an SEO the software the launch
nicey oh yeah yeah so this is the these
success cases that you've had with
organizations so so what how would how
would someone interested in launching
their I co use the MB safe software we
allow you they allow companies to get
ready to launch their SEO in two weeks
or less instead of like six instead of
four to six months that they would
otherwise and on rebellion all the tack
of course now because of the competition
all these times like went down and a lot
of similar offerings on the market but
up until 2017 it's been taking companies
years to develop bullets for their new
clipped occurrences and we automated
this process we allowed you allowed
companies to launch new cryptocurrency
in less than a month so and coming back
to financial inclusion what why ICO
became a killer app it made it like
irrelevant of where you are located no
matter where you are if you have a good
idea and you can present an online
community you can raise money for your
idea so if the concept launched yes so
if the concept of I co-exist at
in 2011 I could have raised money for my
cryptocurrencies project we're all still
in Ukraine but by then I have to travel
to San Francisco to get some funding
whereas now even in the most markets in
the world where it's just $2 a day or so
in what people are being paid that with
a very powerful idea in connection of
the Internet one can potentially raise
money from areas of the world that make
hundreds of dollars that I a and so then
that could really kick start things off
yeah that's very powerful so then this
is a embassy this is providing kind of a
bedrock for people to be able to build
their I see us through an all right hop
of and then does the Samba safe just
take a percentage of the funds raised
it's out how you guys get most of the
money on software license in grief we've
tried a lot of things including taking
percentage there are a lot of nuances
there different I gotcha okay okay cool
all right and then all right and then
let's go let's go into so that's so
that's both on the the very early stage
companies launching their token
offerings that part then there's the the
tokenizing equity of pre IPO companies
so it's both from the very small level
around around the world starting their I
SEOs but it's also on the massive
companies that are pre IPO such as
SpaceX that you're working on right now
and this is crazy because this is like a
50 million dollar investment that you're
purchasing the the shares through US
capital global partners and then that
and then for someone to get involved in
this they only need $100 minimum
investment yes so this is the next stage
of development of them of the market in
2017 most of the people in this space
realized that most of the tokens are
actually securities and they have to be
handled as a securities and sold of the
Securities and so on
but once you switch from utility talking
model to security token model it becomes
much more difficult to sell because
there are much fewer things to speculate
about while with utility tokens you can
easily promise that the next day they
will be used at space stations and
coffee machines and I don't know every
piece of infrastructure in the world
with securities you can't say anything
like that it's it's much more clear what
securities are there financial
instrument supplies engine equity or
some debt obligation in the company and
investors know how they work
investors know growth patterns they
understand that security will not be
worth like 30 times more the next day
just because it isn't the blockchain the
company actually has to deliver some
results has to execute on their idea so
even though there are a lot of buzz and
events still going on around security
tokens if you take a little bit closer
look there aren't actually any like
public sales of security tokens that
were successful most of them were funded
privately during roadshow in somewhat
traditional way of financing so most of
the security token offerings are failing
because they are just not really
different from any start appraisin money
on with paper based equity so because we
made a lot of birds on the security
token market including lunch and order
book the trading platform for security
tokens I had to send like how to make
this market take off so what was missing
apparently is a high quality high demand
high quality high demand security tokens
so it has to be offering by a company
that is already successful but uber and
there
and be and others it's it's a it's an
additional risk for them they are not
really interested in offering their
their equity we are talking of him just
because they cap so I brought yeah I I
went to my investment-banking friends
and we sat and brainstormed for a little
and we found a way to tokenize equity of
of successful pipe your companies
legally without having to to to get
their participation so we'll just buy it
on the secondary market and put in the
fund and offer the equity of the fund
yes so it's it's a form of derivative
it's not a direct equity as if it was
issued by uber directly on the
blockchain
it's like one step away in the legal
structure yes
but the economic value is similar and we
have yeah this was interesting too you
know on the website on you know SpaceX
order book that IOU you used to mention
the legal disclaimer the offerings not
available to the residents of the
following countries so why is it not
available to us Australia Brasilia can
get especially near a kingdom yes so if
you are investor in one of these
countries it is much easier for you to
buy buy this equity on the secondary
market if you really want we are
focusing on Financial Inclusion we are
focusing on the developed developing
countries where people make several
hundred bucks per month and this is why
we are trying to solve the problem for
six billion people instead of several
million who who have other ways to
invest also those also the countries
that are listed there already have the
ability to they're wealthy enough to
purchase a directly right I mean there
are still a lot of opportunities there
but the cost of lunch and the suffering
there is much higher like we go all the
preparations like filing for regulation
soon while most of the developing
countries like Indonesia Vietnam and
others they haven't even issued a
regulation about
the legal status of security tokens it
will take for them couple years years to
understand what is it so it was if you
can come in and buy without having to go
through the red tape yeah it's kind of a
gray area but we are not scammers we are
not doing anything bad so I think it's
yeah it's a win-win yes yes okay okay so
June 10th this is gonna be available so
in about a month
available for countries around the world
that were that were not listed there
that they can then have a 100 dollar
minimum investment into having a token
that rep that is a representative part
of the shares of space yes so one of the
interesting things we've done here is
the token represents a share in the
company while in most offerings in most
offerings token is some contractual
promise or obligation of a company in
the way we incorporated this fund is the
token is an actual share the bylaws of
the fund says that the this class of
shares u.s. PX is represented by tokens
based on the helium so by buying a token
you're buying share in the fund and the
fund holds equity of the SpaceX yeah
yeah and the minimal price we are going
to sell it is 100 bucks as if you try to
do similar rhythm today in minority like
if you try to get into SpaceX or uber or
other companies before the IPO it would
probably cost you between $25,000 and
million dollars so we are significantly
dropping the minimal that the entry
barrier and making it available to
broader population yes yes on a another
conversation that we have later it'll be
good to dive deeper into the
technicalities of how a company that
there's an idea from around the world
wants to have go through Amba safes
platform because I think it'd be
interesting for people to learn about
how they can start
their own token offering out half people
help fund their company from around the
world how that works on a technical
level and then same thing with this as
well we can get deeper into the
technical nuance of how exactly a
hundred dollar investment goes through
the order book here and how I have this
digital ownership where I store it all
this type of stuff how I can then go and
get it back out yeah it's a little
complex combination of like legal and
technical structure it it's it's all
explained on the website awesome okay
it's all explained on Amba safe end on
the work on the order book here yeah
okay okay okay cool cool and then and
then hopefully you can get to a point
where you're starting to do this pre IPO
ownership tokenization actually for a
lot of the companies that are that look
like they're becoming trillion dollar
companies that way you can take the
money that's being concentrated in the
1% and give people the ability to come
in and that's the financial inclusion
yes so this is the plan we are going to
so currently only sent hill road funds
and like I said by area VC funds they're
about the only ones who who get access
to this unicorns and by launching this
platform this combination of of legal
and technical setup we making this
opportunity available to the rest of the
people worldwide so yes we are planning
to organize more unicorns yeah prefer to
not disclose the names in advance but
this is how a plan so to breathe in some
life in the security tokens market and
once it becomes mature enough earlier
stage companies can also participate I
love that model tokenizing unicorns
that's a good one and also financial
inclusion that's what that really is
such a pressing thing as we see more and
more wealth being concentrated and like
you said why is it that only some of the
Silicon Valley venture cap
funds are the ones able to do the the
Serie C rounds of hundreds of millions
of dollars in these companies when to be
able to democratize that is a very
beautiful way to include financially
let's hit
let's hit how the United States is half
of all I see owes right now
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah it's like the
general pattern of the market share
whenever you launch any online business
you usually get 50% of sales in the US
and the rest the other 50 is distributed
worldwide okay yes so the US economy is
as big as the rest of the world's
economies combined yeah it's crazy
as the rest of the world's combined
yeah oh man so that means 50% the US and
the 50%
yeah China is a little bit taken is
isolated I'm not sure how it plays in
this picture but if you analyze sales
revenue for like most of the like global
online businesses you will see that 50%
is sold in the US and the other 50 is
the rest yeah so it could be something
like 50 US 30 China and then the
breakdown is like 3% 4% blah blah less
yeah okay
and then within then that would be
another interesting question is kind of
how do you see it evolving with
cryptocurrencies and blockchain
technology how do you see it evolving
geopolitically I think blockchain is
kind of a policeman for governments
whenever some government is trying to do
something weird whenever economic crisis
like hyperinflation happens like it has
happened several times in Argentina in
Venezuela and Turkey other countries
whenever it happens the local population
no longer goes to the banks and and in
whenever it happens government restricts
the populations ability to to exit their
fiat currency their national currency to
buy dollars whenever the crisis happens
you're usually unable to exchange your
national currency two dollars to protect
yourself from inflation and Bitcoin
provides a solution for that problem now
whenever the crisis is whenever the
crisis happens people no longer rushed
by dollars people rush to buy bitcoins
whenever some government [ __ ] up people
exit from national currency to Bitcoin
yeah so you can see that Bitcoin price
spikes every time there is a crisis
anywhere in the world so now it's like a
policeman for any government if
government does something wrong with the
economy people will have an alternative
people will have escaped the currency
market they
access from any internet-connected
device what an interesting analogy is
the policeman of the world that are
making sure that the corruption doesn't
get too far
you see far yeah and that we transition
away from centralization over time where
else the decentralized consensus
technology is a fascinating thing we
want a future where we all have where it
can all be educated enough have enough
time to become educated enough to make
some sort of a say in the direction of
civilization where else do you see the
consensus technology having sure very
good question
anywhere as long as there is a business
process were at least a single piece of
paper involved there is a potential for
disruption by blockchain what's really
disruptive about the blockchain is that
it moves business processes or any kind
of processes that require
Standardization into the digital form
and standardized asset consensus is is a
form of a standard how you circulate
agreement between the parties and it's
done in digital form so what blockchain
actually does is it removes the
paperwork it converts the paperwork into
the standardized digital transactions
with digital identity and once it
happens it accelerates this process by
the factor of like 100x or more it makes
it thousand X cheaper more transparent
and so on so blockchain is moving all
transactions from paper to digital form
any kind of transactions any kind of
paperwork and you like boring
bureaucratic work that people hate today
will be moved to some blockchain based
platform eventually like getting on
approvals from various government
agencies to sell the house for example
you have to visit five different offices
get an appraisal get some signatures
from the banker from the city and so on
once it is on the blockchain like one of
the companies I'm advising property is
moving into the digital form it can be
done entirely online in less than an
hour
instead of having to spend weeks on like
walking to the offices so the smart
contract is created between you and I
for you to move of an asset in the
physical world to my ownership and then
the funds are transferred to you
digitally and this is all made on a
decent guys ledger that's immutable that
this happened yeah it doesn't have to
involve the transfer of funds at all
it's a matter of representing all the
participants in digital form as long as
everyone has a digital identity like a
pair of keys private and public you can
interact online instead of heaven so
prints can paper over like go meat and
so on yes yes okay and then even to the
degree where it's something as as you
know these unique identifiers and is an
interesting thing who assigns these
unique identifiers or is my unique
identifier public it's up to you to
decide onion
how do you find software is really
flexible you can really implement any
like business requirements if it makes
sense to make it public we'll make it
public if you don't want for example
with kyc we want to know the security
token transfers we wants to know which
others has went through kyc which public
key has been a stroke away cyc yeah kyc
brothers know your customer new yorkers
yes so we don't want to transfer
securities to any unaccredited
or a non Kawai seed person so we store
at the record of who went through kyc in
the public forum like we mark addresses
as kyc publicly but we don't upload any
of the private data like the actual
first and last name in my addresses and
so on they all kept privately in in the
KYC providers databases so whatever is
required usually it's the information
that is generally about
in government registries like DMV
violations or like property titles
database or stuff like that
if it's public there will make it public
on the blockchain so the software is
extremely agile though so it can be so
it's really cool how the how it can the
applications these are very endless
there's things and biometrics that are
very interesting there's things an
identity that are interesting and
transfer of goods in the physical world
in the digital world with smart
contracts okay and I hope that we can
make some sort of a geopolitical
consensus as well with way that we want
to move so still find still incentivize
innovation but at the same time have
more cohesion with the environment and
with each other so we're not we're
alleviating suffering fact yeah I think
blockchain will also bring people into
more agreements on a global scale
because once you move all participants
to online or digital forums it becomes
much easier for them to communicate with
each other it removes fiction yes and
communication goes faster yes so the
faster communication is the faster
people will agree on any issue yeah and
then what would you say is a skill that
every child should know going into the
exponential technology age scale a skill
a skill yeah yeah understanding of
public key cryptography
is a must like what is digital signature
how how to verify digital signature it's
yeah I think it's it's a must-have
nowadays to be able to to verify that
the piece of information that you've
just received from somebody is coming
from from that person instead of someone
else Wow knowing cryptography knowing
that you sent me this and that it's not
some obscure entity that's trying to
pretend that it's you yeah knowing that
would for example allow you to to see
which of the messengers like Facebook
and
sup who claimed to be protected and
private are actually private mmm and
they will be surprised
can you teach us about what you found
about that yeah most of them on our
Taylor are not encrypted
they are encrypted but the company the
service provider can change keys on the
on the fly without mattifying you so
they have no value as long as you are
not in control of the keys you're not in
control of the keys yeah of the
encryption keys interesting yeah there's
a lot still to unpack about encryption
okay let's ask you the couple questions
that we asked on the way out of the
episode okay the first question is are
we alone in the cosmos it doesn't seem
like that if you do basic I just look
for UFO videos on YouTube you will find
a lot like thousands of hours of various
UFO videos thinking logically even if
90% of them are fake even if there is
some conspiracy of video editors and
photo shoppers all around the world who
applauded in them randomly from random
locations every day non-stop and 90% of
those videos are fake because there is
this conspiracy of Photoshop as
worldwide there is still 10% remains
even if it's 1% it's it's enough to
prove that we are not alone
right and then how about we venture into
the simulation theory simulation theorem
are we in a simulation I think we are
okay it's it's a it's a speech so let me
download the context okay so my take on
this is that the phenomenons of quantum
physics much easier to explain with
simulation theory than with other very
complex theories that physic researchers
are coming up with like string theory
you are not even able to understand it
so the basic idea of this like how to
understand quantum physics is a computer
optimization if you are familiar with
computer games or any kind of
computer-based environment like you can
try walking Google Maps with your phone
in front of you it doesn't render the
places until you get there in this
simulated environment when you switch
when you just finished some some level
in a computer game it takes a couple of
minutes to load the next level it's not
render it it's not loaded until you are
there do not waste computation to not
waste computer resources on something
that nobody is is washing quantum
effects seem to be really similar the
universe doesn't render things that
nobody is looking at it's much simpler
explanation that we actually can
simulate and understand with our modern
technology than all this like string and
multiverse theories so this is one of
the arguments another one is most of the
religions actually tell you if you if
you remove all the all the [ __ ] that
they accumulated with thousands of years
most of the religions they tell you that
we have kind of some immortal soul or a
spirit outside of this world and we came
to this world to learn something it's a
temporary world we are here temporarily
and once we are out we
we'll reflect on what we did and so on
so it's kind of a common theme that is
going through all the religions that
this world is not as real as as it
appears and it is confirmed by
psychedelic experiences most of the
people who have tried DMT they also
reported that they they meet outside of
this world with some more advanced
creatures that and they see their past
lives and they mean their dead relatives
so people the main problem that they see
here is that every religion every
spiritual or psychedelic researcher is
using their own terminology there is a
lack of common terminology to describe
this thing everyone is kind of talking
different language there are thousands
of different languages to describe the
same thing but if you actually create a
data model like a software architect if
you map objects that people I described
in using software tools the structure
looks 90% identical in every description
whether you talk to some shaman in
Mexico or or some I don't know
psychedelic researcher in San Francisco
they describe very similar structure
like we have we have some body or soul
outside and it's plugged into this
environment to learn some lessons and
there are many iterations to learn it
takes many many iterations of the game
into learning the lessons mm-hm and this
is what people described as incarnation
and that there's so many things there
one of the things is the saving compute
on render that's a frequent one that we
hear I like that one a lot and seems to
make lots of sense also that there's so
many reasons to simulate there's so many
things to learn
about what actually happens to
civilizations as they evolve all this
type of stuff and then of course the
role-playing characters that we play in
this game in that word what are we
learning we're learning lessons how many
times does it take for us to learn the
lesson with what degree percentage
success did you learn that lesson maybe
when you only learn 70% you have to
replay the level replay the the 80 year
life that you're here maybe these are
all very interesting questions the past
life líneas well how a shaman and
psychedelic adventure interplay with all
of this it's yeah it's good stuff we can
spend a whole nother session talking
about just this I'll be good I just want
to give a big shout out to ho PNG who's
been watching you the whole show he
thinks you're a really cool guy and yeah
thanks for watching hope you yeah hope
he's actually been commenting quite a
bit over the last couple months so a
huge shout out to Opie thank you thank
you we've heart we've liked and and
replied to a lot of their comments did
you just assume their gender how could
you run did I would I say yeah one more
question but yeah go ahead yeah well one
really important difference between how
most of the proponents of simulation
theory understand that in between and
between me how I understand that most of
the people who evangelize simulation
theory they believe that we exist only
in the form of software so if the
computer is switched off we disappear
while religious experiences and
psychedelic experiences tell us that we
actually have bodies outside that the
temporarily plugged into the computer is
an equivalent of putting the VR headset
on your head yeah so this is the main
difference yes okay so this difference
is also important because one of them is
like oh just unplug it from the switch
and the other one is that no you've
actually spiritually decided that you're
going to go into this experience and
that there is no plugging or unplugging
this is a process that you go through to
learn
yeah I'm type of thing yeah okay and
that whatever the solar spirit or the
decision power is pre-birth and whatever
it is after death is something else that
we'll have to yeah unpack
Andre this has been so interesting last
question is what do you think is the
most beautiful thing in the world the
most beautiful thing in the world
let me think about it there take your
time there are so many beautiful things
in the world
okay I think it's the universe itself if
you can imagine that on a large scale
the more you understand that the more
details you can imagine the the more oh
and like beauty you are you see yeah
yeah yeah it's it's a difficult question
it's such a pleasure thank you thank you
thank you for coming on the show thanks
for teaching us about all that you're
working on it's very important working
getting us the financial inclusion good
job thank you keep up the great work and
we have to do a whole nother session on
simulation Theory together I'll be
really fun
okay huge thank you everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on financial inclusion on what we're
talking about with cryptocurrency and
blockchain do check out the links below
to order book do and be safe calm holy
transaction calm the spacex doubt order
book do that goes on June 10th minimum
hundred dollar investment check that out
on the also Andres Twitter check all
that out huge shout out to Ron Vargas
we're producing and directing much love
we love you very much and share content
like this with other people your friends
your family or coworkers online on
social media get talking more about
Financial Inclusion let's do it everyone
let's get there together and go and
build the future everyone support
simulation so we can continue building
this project as well artists
entrepreneurs organizations around the
world that you believe and support them
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see
[Music]